pour trouver des idées certains
journalistes se sont rendus à 20 et
saveurs au salon 20 et saveurs de Poissy
et on y trouvait plusieurs produits
plusieurs produits locaux comme des vins
des bières ou encore des biscuits
originales vous nous avez concocté
plusieurs une petite sélection
exactement et parmi leurs trouvailles
une épicerie que l'on nomme les deux
gourmands cette épicerie s'est Audi par
l'histoire de Louis et de Guillaume des
amis passionnés par la gastronomie et
l'agriculture tous deux ont décidé de
créer des biscuits composés de produits
locaux il propose également du pain du
pain d'épices pardon des bonbons et du
miel de région on écoute Marie Le
Pelletier une des collaboratrices qui
nous donne ces indispensables pour Noël
au micro de Michael el midoro alors le
pain d'épice évidemment si vous avez du
foie gras et que notre pain d'épices
c'est voilà excellent
et après si vous voulez faire des
petites sauces au miel évidemment et
puis nos biscuits apéro pour l'apéro
et alors où est-ce qu'on peut trouver
cette épicerie Régine dans un ancien
corps de ferme à Crespières et vous avez
aussi d'autres idées de boissons plutôt
on a fait la découverte de la brasserie
de la reine qui est tenue par un père et
son fils il produit 400 hectolitres par
an et se situe à Rambouillet dans la
zone du Bel Air le producteur nous a
montré quelques unes de leurs bières on
l'écoute la blanche qui est une bière de
malt d'or j'ai mal de blé ensuite on a
une blonde qui refait à peu près 40% de
nos volumes c'est une blonde classique
avec une amertume légère
en cette saison on a une bière de Noël
donc une bière de Noël on produit à peu
près 1000 litres par an et donc ceux qui
ont la chance de la boire c'est des
privilégiés on peut dire on rappellera
bien sûr Régine que l'alcool est à
consommer avec modération exactement
mais pour terminer je vous propose tout
de même de découvrir la bouche du roi
une marque de vin fondée en 2017 et
dessiné à faire revivre le vignoble
francilien situé en pleine de Versailles
à d'Avron les vignes sont cultivées sans
pestifs sans pesticides Bastien au sa
vie l'un des fondateurs de la marque
nous conseille quelques vins pour
accompagner vos plats en l'écoute je
vous conseille le chenin en entrée avec
les huîtres ou fruits de mer si jamais
vous avez la chance dans dans déguster
pendant les fêtes et ensuite
je dirais moi mon préféré c'est le pinot
noir en rouge sinon un assemblage merlot
cabernet franc il y avait parfaitement
avec une dinde ou les plats habituels
les fêtes de Noël
alors merci beaucoup Régine relève pour
toutes ces idées de cadeaux